se tumbó una reforma tributaria que no
recogía el sentir de la población
colombiana ni personas doctas en
economía ni las personas de a pie que
hacen mercado en la esquina se sentían
reflejadas se sentían respetadas con una
reforma tributaria tercera bajo el
gobierno de duke que buscaba ahondar la
brecha entre los más ricos y los más
pobres colombia son los países con mayor
inequidad en el mundo y la reforma
tributaria no buscaba más que ahondar en
ese modelo por eso más allá de
discusiones tecnocráticas que les
encanta mencionar a los señores
defensores del gobierno lo que uno
encuentra de fondo es que la gente dijo
nomás no vamos a pagar más impuestos
mientras el gobierno se gasta unas
millonadas de peso queriendo comprar
aviones de guerra o en términos de la
corrupción y en términos sociales yo veo
un gran despertar de la sociedad
especialmente de los jóvenes de sectores
importantes que vemos ahora mismo en en
imagen como el sector salud
diferentes hoy marcharon por ejemplo los
recicladores los indígenas y son el
reflejo de él el fiel reflejo de un país
que no se siente reconocido ni en los
partidos políticos ni tampoco en la
institucionalidad entonces lo que se
demuestra aquí primero es que las calles
son capaces de tumbar una reforma
agraria y tributaria de tumbar a un
ministro y de imponer una agenda
política que sea más acorde a la
realidad no se puede seguir gobernando
de espalda al país ahora víctor porque
de presentar el proyecto ahora y porque
ir directamente con un plan tan
ambicioso y agresivo si se quiere para
la clase media colombiana además le
pregunto cuál es la situación la
situación real y actual el fiscal de
colombia
a ver colombia es un país de renta media
donde no es un país pobre el problema no
tiene que ver con la disponibilidad de
recursos tiene que ver con esos recursos
para dónde van y cómo se manejan y con
qué criterios se manejan por ejemplo en
materia de salud nosotros tenemos muchos
recursos en salud pero esos recursos se
los apropia el intermediario financiero
llamado en colombia' ips que es la que
regula la relación entre los hospitales
y las los pacientes igual podríamos
mirar con diferentes sectores cuando uno
piensa como un gobierno reparte el
presupuesto pues vemos que hay un gran
presupuesto para la lucha armada para
las fuerzas armadas pero hay un bajo
presupuesto en términos por ejemplo de
educación solo para dar un dato la
semana pasada según cifras oficiales
demuestran que el 42 por ciento
de la población colombiana 21 millones
de personas están por debajo de la línea
de pobreza 3 una no puede nosotros no
entendemos como frente a un drama tan
grande se cae en el error de querer
cobrarle a la gente de seguirle sacando
los recursos a la gente es más de si
revisamos cómo se supone se supera la
crisis de la gran depresión del 29 y el
plan marchas de la segunda guerra
mundial pues lo que encontramos es que
el estado juega un papel de inversor
para reactivar la economía aquí se han
presentado siete proyectos indicando de
dónde se puede sacar plata para la renta
básica para que la gente pueda comer
comprar reactivar la economía sin
embargo el gobierno no hace caso a ello
si había destinado una ingente cantidad
de dinero para la aerolínea avianca que
ni siquiera es una aerolínea que esté
que sea colombiana ha habido una
cantidad de recursos para comprar
equipos de vigilancia y modernizar
sistemas de escoltas en el país en medio
de la crisis no ha habido una gestión
adecuada
de la pandemia entonces la crisis
estructural de injusticia y de iniquidad
más la crisis de pobreza de los últimos
años que hizo aguas en el año 2019 más
el manejo de la pandemia que a todas
luces y con datos estadísticos y números
claros demuestran la gran equivocación
de la política frente a la pandemia se
suman estos tres criterios para explicar
por qué se vuelca a la ciudadanía a
partir del 28 de abril a las calles y
porque además víctor le preguntó el
presidente de duke y su gobierno
intentaron poner esta reforma tributaria
en medio de este tercer pico de la
pandemia de kobe 19 donde la gente está
cansada del encierro cansada de no poder
trabajar pues evidentemente los recursos
han mermado en la sociedad colombiana
calcularon bien el costo político
yo creo que no ellos me parece que el
problema de los gobiernos autoritarios
que gobiernan dándole la espalda al país
es que no miden la responsabilidad que
tienen en materia de incendiar el país
que está incendiando el país no son los
jóvenes algunos de ellos muertos en las
calles colombianas no son las políticas
sociales que la gente ya no aguanta es
decir no es posible que en colombia se
le quieran poner impuestos agregados a
los huevos al café colombia un país que
produce café el café colombiano tan
famoso bueno pues ahora con nuevo
impuesto a una cantidad de cosas decir
que el azúcar no es un producto esencial
decir a la gente que se toma un café con
azúcar para ir a comenzar el trabajo ya
recibiría un impuesto del 19 por ciento
es absolutamente injusto es colocarle
impuestos a las honras fúnebres o sea la
sentencia ya no tenemos derecho ni a
morirnos eso es una realidad es decir
ahí están los números los estudios
estadísticos las propuestas para creer
que no es sobra ni de un compló de
internacional
y de una una red de organizaciones del
narcoterrorismo como está diciendo el
gobierno nuestro es un paro que se más
donde la gente está saliendo en los
barrios las imágenes que ustedes están
mostrando en este momento son de gente
joven de gente con pancartas con música
tratando de decir oiga escúchenos yo
creo que sé qué es realmente y la
palabra es infamia es infame tratar de
representar un clamor constitucional el
derecho de la gente la protesta
reducirlo a un problema de vandalismo
luego de ese de vandalismo saltamos a un
discurso de que no es vandalismo sino
terrorismo y a partir de ahí justificar
unas cosas terribles que precisamente
instituciones como el congreso los eeuu
ha salido a condenar que la unión
europea ha habido ha salido a condenar
entonces no es una alcahuetería ni una
falta de tacto ni un problema de
terrorismo y vandalismo es una protesta
social que la comunidad internacional
está
y discutiendo y lo que muestra el
fracaso del gobierno en su gestión
política económica y social